in the past few billion years Earth has
been pummeled by asteroids crashed into
other planets and frozen over several
times not to mention being ruled by all
kinds of crazy life
forms sometimes it's a wonder that our
blue home world has survived at all but
if we want to take a whirlwind tour of
our planet's history we'll have to start
way back at the very
beginning some 4 and A2 billion years
ago our solar system began to emerge out
of a dense cloud of interstellar gas and
dust This Cloud collapsed into a
swirling disc of matter that got hotter
and hotter and hotter until Hy hydrogen
fused into
helium and just like that our son was
born and baby Earth was on its way too
after the birth of our star all the
matter on the farthest ends of the
spinning disc began to Clump together
these clumps would be the seedlings for
the planets and moons in our solar
system as they accumulated more matter
they grew bigger and more spherical the
clumps in the cool regions of the solar
system were mostly made of ice liquids
and gases closer to the Sun all the
rocky material formed the inner planets
like Mars and Earth this young Earth was
incredibly active volcanically speaking
it spewed out gases like hydrogen
sulfide methane and carbon
dioxide these gases made up the very
first atmosphere on our planet early
Earth was constantly bombarded by large
asteroids and comets and soon Earth
experienced an even more violent
Collision Thea a planet the size of Mars
slammed right into our Young World this
epic Collision threw chunks of matter
all around Earth's orbit and then
gravity bound them together into what we
know now as the
[Music]
Moon
on this hot early Earth there were no
oceans all water existed as
gas but 3.8 billion years ago our planet
cooled enough for water to condensate
and become liquid the very first
primitive ocean covered this young Earth
and turned it into a water world H2O is
an essential ingredient for creating
living things so with all that water
life appeared on Earth about 3.7 billion
years ago these earliest forms of life
were microscopic organisms but it was
nearly a billion years after that that
some of these organisms changed the
course of the
[Music]
world Earth didn't stay as a water world
very long soon the very first continents
emerged from the ancient ocean
scientists call them
cratons as more and more land Rose from
the ocean the very first supercontinent
appeared on the planet valbar wasn't
exactly a super continent it was pretty
small scientists think it was smaller
than the continent of
[Music]
Australia around 2.4 billion years ago
cyanobacteria evolved to become our
planet's first
photosynthesizers finally we had some
oxygen producers to make Earth's
atmosphere much more hospitable and the
rest is history
folks just kidding we've still got a
long way to
go with all this new oxygen Earth's
atmosphere had much lower levels of
carbon dioxide and that made the planet
icy cold much of our Young World froze
over as Earth saw its first Ice
Age now as Earth's atmosphere was
changing the continents were moving too
they broke up and reassembled into the
next supercontinent
rodinia rodinia was a real
supercontinent it may have been the
largest supercontinent to ever cover the
planet and life well life finally became
more comp complex but then something
happened rodinia broke apart and a new
supercontinent assembled this one was
called
pinosa then between about 540 and
485 million years ago there was an
explosion of new life this time was
called the Cambrian explosion and the
animals that evolved during this period
had heart hard body parts like shells or
spines the most famous of all were the
alien looking
[Music]
trilobites around 440 million years ago
the climate suddenly shifted and the
temperature of the ocean changed
dramatically Earth saw its first mass
extinction event this was the or
division silurian Extinction and a
majority of the the life that had been
spreading around the planet
vanished many of these life forms laid
the foundation for the ecosystems that
we have on Earth today somewhere between
420 to 350 million years ago the first
trees arose from Earth's soil and the
first animals made their way to land
too 250 million years ago the planet was
covered by Our Last vast supercontinent
Pangia sadly it was also during this
period that Earth witnessed the greatest
mass extinction event in our history the
great
dying huge amounts of greenhouse gases
and accelerated global warming wiped out
about 90% of all species on Earth but
this mass extinction helped pave the way
for the next wave of animals to evolve
240 to 230 million years ago the first
dinosaurs appeared for the
next50 million years they'd rule the
land if you were there you'd have
witnessed the gigantic sorod
Argentinosaurus the largest land animal
ever or you might have been chased by
one of the earth's greatest apex
predators the
T-Rex and you'd also witness Pangia
breaking up and forming the continents
we know
today okay you may already know where
this is
headed 66 million years ago an asteroid
slammed into our planet right where
Mexico sits now and it coughed up so
much debris into the atmosphere that it
blocked out the sun this led to
devastating climate changes that caused
the dinosaurs to die out
in the next wave of emerging animals
mammals became more
[Music]
common around 6 million years ago the
earliest known humans started walking
this world this species was called
sahelanthropus though they still likely
walked on all fours 4 million years ago
early humans began to walk upright and
about 1 million years later they
developed the first known two tools
which they used to break things some
800,000 years ago things sparked these
early humans discovered how to control
fire and could now cook food and provide
themselves with heat their brains
continued to evolve now more rapidly
than ever these humans learned to
interact with each other and the
surrounding World in whole new ways then
between 40,000 to 15,000 years ago
all other human species besides Homo
sapiens went
extinct 10,000 years ago Earth saw its
earliest Farmers these previously
nomadic humans stopped wandering the
planet and finally put down their Roots
jumping way forward to about 250 years
ago the Industrial Revolution took place
we went through major technological
socioeconomic and cultural
Transformations rural-based Farm
societies became more industrialized
Urban ones our human population
continued to grow by 1804 we reached 1
billion by 1927 we'd hit 2 billion and
since the 1960s the global population
has risen faster and faster to where it
is now at over 8 billion people what
will humans look like in 10,000 years
what about in 1 million years will we
look like this guy n probably not but
we'll definitely look different than we
do now what parts of our body would
evolve how long would evolving our
bodies
take and who would win the survival of
the
fittest this is what if and here's what
would happen if if our bodies kept
evolving it took roughly 6 million years
for humans to become what we are today
and modern humans have only been around
for about 12,000 of those years even in
that short period of time humans have
evolved slightly we've become about 10
cm taller and now we can eat dairy foods
after childhood so if those things can
happen in 12,000 years where might we be
hundreds of thousands of years into the
future first we should probably figure
out exactly what evolution is evolution
is all about changes in the genetic
makeup that happen to a species over
time species with more advantageous
traits will tend to have more offspring
so those genetic traits will tend to
carry on to later generations for
example giraffes with longer necks who
can reach more food will be able to
survive better than giraffes with short
necks and they'll be able to have more
babies who will likely have longer necks
just like their parents and as time goes
on the short neck giraffes will die out
and the long neck giraffes are the only
ones left that's why all our giraffes
today have long
necks so how does this apply to humans
exactly well evolution in this sense is
actually very hard to predict in the
world we live in we don't need need to
worry about survival of the fittest
technology has effectively canel a lot
of that you no longer need to worry
about being the fastest or the strongest
this isn't 100,000 years ago when you
had to fight for your
food things like houses to live in and
clean running water make surviving so
much easier you never think to yourself
how am I going to survive today but
that's something our ancestors had to
worry about constantly it's not guarant
guaranteed that 1 million years from now
humans will be stronger faster and
bigger than ever before after all having
children today is generally decided by
culture and personal choice rather than
the need for our species to
survive our future will be decided by
the traits of people who have children
and how many children they have if
people who are naturally overweight and
have health problems are the only ones
having kids over the next million years
then
that's how the human race will end up
but we might not need to worry about any
of these natural
occurrences instead we could become
completely fused with technology before
any of this happens cybernetic arms
brain chips and laser eyes could all
become
possibilities not only that but we also
might be able to alter a baby's genes
before they're born completely getting
rid of evolution altogether
this would allow us to get rid of
diseases and any other genetic traits
that might harm
us but if we didn't have this luxury and
we had to evolve the old-fashioned way
there's a few things that might happen
we just need to look at how modern
humans have evolved in the past 12,000
years we know we've been getting taller
most likely due to nutrition and that
our brains have been getting smaller but
don't worry we haven't been getting
Dumber our brains are actually becoming
more efficient so in a million years we
might be incredibly tall humans with
tiny heads does that remind you of
anything at the end of the day human
evolution is incredibly difficult to
predict that's because evolution is
primarily based on our environment and
who knows what might happen to the Earth
in the next million years we might need
to evolve to survive fires as the planet
will become so incredibly
hot I so hope I'm not around for that if
you traveled
250 million years into the past you'd be
witnessing the dawn of
Dinosaurs one of the leading theories is
that dinosaurs evolved from a species
known as archosaurs these were the
dominant reptiles that appeared during
the late perian period to some they may
even look like dinosaurs and that's
because they were ancestors to to these
incredible creatures over time the
archosaurs split up into two groups one
of these groups led to crocodiles and
the other led to dinosaurs which
continued evolving into thousands of
different species one of the main traits
they eventually gained was their bipedal
abilities early dinosaurs began to walk
on two legs freeing their front limbs
for other uses like grabbing food and
defending themselves and that that's
just the start of their evolutionary
Journey let's travel back in time 250
million years ago and witness the
history of dinosaurs in 10
minutes Triassic
period as you enter this new era you'll
notice that the dinosaurs running around
look pretty different from what you're
used to seeing one of the earliest
dinosaurs that emerged from the
archosaurs was the Eoraptor this little
guy was about the size of a dog barely 1
M tall and weighing in at a meager 10 kg
you know we typically think of dinosaurs
as these massive creatures but it' be a
couple million more years before that
started to happen we'll check in to see
how those dinos are growing in size as
we travel through time but for now let's
see what's happening to Earth during the
Triassic period the supercontinent
Pangia starts to fragment slowly
altering Global climates and ecosystems
the climate was generally hot and dry
and there were no polar ice caps
creating a stark contrast to what you're
typically used to in modern-day Earth
the vegetation was also very different
and was crucial for the survival and
evolution of dinosaurs the plants have
different characteristics as well some
are tough some nutritious and others
potentially poisonous each one of them
will influence the dietary and adaptive
strategies of different dinosaur species
speaking of of which what are some other
dinosaurs doing during this time
weighing in at about 23 kg and 1 M tall
we have the celop fisis it was a little
bit bigger than the Eoraptor but that
didn't stop it from being a fast and
agile Predator that likely prayed on
smaller animals now the herrerasaurus
was slightly taller at about 1.1 M but
was a lot heavier at about 350
kg then we have the plateosaurus now
this sky is way bigger than me it stood
tall at about 3 m and weighed up to
4,000 kgrs this was one of the earliest
examples of how big dinosaurs could grow
but wait they get even bigger than this
despite their impressive forms dinosaurs
weren't the dominant creatures during
the Triassic they had to share their
environments with many other organisms
all vying for survival in the diverse
ecosystems
this was the case until the Triassic
period would experience a great
Extinction event this was likely caused
by Massive volcanic activity climate
change and potentially even some small
asteroid
impacts this will have a significant
effect on life on Earth and lead to the
extinction of numerous species but it
wasn't all bad especially for our
dinosaurs this moment set the stage to
bring new opportunities to these species
leading to them dominating the
Earth Jurassic
Period now instead of dinosaurs simply
surviving this is where they
Thrive over the millions of years
different species have been evolving and
dinosaurs are now the rulers of the
earth they spread across continents
dominating the Lush forests and arid
deserts occupying these areas were some
massive dinosaurs ones that you're
probably a lot more familiar with we
have the stegosaurus brachiosaurus and
Allosaurus these were some of the
largest creatures ever to walk the earth
but you'd quickly notice that it wasn't
just these massive beasts that were
roaming around this era also saw the
evolution of
theropods these were smaller dinosaurs
that had more of a bird-like form one of
the most famous was the archaeopteris it
was kind of like a mix between a
dinosaur and a bird with feathers and
wings but also with bony teeth and a
tail the archaeopteris was a crucial
link between birds and dinosaurs if you
wait about 100 million more years
they'll evolve into the birds we know
today oh wait is that a
spoiler after 56 million years the
Jurassic period comes to an end this was
after yet another Extinction event
happened luckily this one is more minor
however due to climate change volcanic
activity and sea levels changing some
species are going
extinct this once again changes the
landscape as the dinosaurs enter their
final
era Cretaceous
Period okay we've now entered the
Cretaceous Period and as we've been
traveling through these millions of
years you may have noticed something's
missing right one of the dinosaurs big
Stars hasn't appeared yet say hello to
the Tyrannosaurus Rex the T-Rex was a
massive Beast it was 3.7 M tall and 12 M
long not only that but it was a whopping
tons equipped with a powerful jaw and
Incredibly sharp teeth the T-Rex
dominated the Cretaceous
Kingdom it was one of the most dominant
Predators history has ever seen this
colossal Beast wasn't just Scavenging
leftovers it was an active Hunter
stalking its prey with Keen eyesight and
a heightened sense of smell among its
favorite meals were the sizable
herbivores like the
Edmontosaurus but the T-Rex didn't stop
there it would take on formidable
opponents like the Triceratops and even
other smaller theropods if the
opportunity arose with its powerful jaws
filled with 12in teeth and its strong
hind limbs that allowed it to run at
speeds of up to 40 kmph the T rex was a
master of the hunt but this period
wasn't just filled with massive beasts
like the
T-Rex look around and you'll also notice
even more feathered dinosaurs in the
Cretaceous Period one of them being the
Velociraptor now you typically see them
portrayed like this with no feathers but
evidence suggests that these creatures
were quite feathered now the feathers
weren't necessarily used for flying more
for warmth and stability and this one is
the micro Raptor now unlike the
Velociraptor its feathers likely were
used for flight giving us crucial
insight into the evolution of birds okay
as I mentioned earlier Pangia was
breaking up and forming into the
continents we know today but because of
this some dinosaurs were forced to
migrate and separate into different
areas of the world these dinosaurs had
to adapt to their new environments
potentially changing the course of their
evolution but none of this matters when
we consider what happens
next the cataclysmic
event okay as you've been hanging out
with the dinosaurs for millions of years
an asteroid has been making its way
toward Earth then suddenly it
hits creating a massive crater 150 km
wide and 20 km
deep naturally something this huge makes
a devastating impact on the world one
that'll change it
forever the asteroid's Collision is
massive but its impact is felt long
after the initial crash due to the
massive Collision the environment
drastically changes significant drops in
temperature start to occur and debris
from the crash begins to block out the
sun this impacts not only the dinosaurs
Health but also their food supply this
devastating event wipes out
75% of the Earth's species many of which
are the dinosaurs we've been observing
this whole time but don't worry not all
of the dinosaurs went extinct the
aviation-based dinosaurs we checked out
earlier managed to survive the asteroid
strike eventually evolving into
Birds
aftermath now that most of the dinosaurs
are EX inct it's cleared the way for
mammals to diversify and expand their
impact on the world with less
competition early mammals can now Thrive
and take over which slowly over time
allowed humans to evolve building the
world we know
today humans have been evolving for the
past 6 million years but but something's
gone terribly wrong and now we're
evolving
backward once this process began how
long would it take for you to become an
ape
again what does climate have to do with
it and why would Society completely
collapse this is what if and here's what
would happen if humans evolved backward
award thanks to Evolution Humanity
dominates Earth but how did that happen
well first don't think of evolution as a
straight and narrow path Evolution
happens through the process of natural
selection over millions of years
organisms adapt to their environments by
developing the traits needed to keep
them alive the life forms that don't
adapt
die Evolution doesn't have an end goal
for you it's a NeverEnding process of
survival so if you started devolving
today how soon would Humanity
perish your journey through Devolution
would eventually take you into the
microscopic realm it should take
billions of years for you to get there
but for the sake of our scenario we're
going to speed this process up like way
up like let's say you raced through the
backward Evolution at the speed of 1
million years in one
day well before you shrunk out of sight
your body would stretch to new heights
well that's good news for my short Kings
out there in just 1 hour you would grow
to around 1.8 m tall
your jaw and teeth would also expand and
your brain size would increase
massively yeah that melon of yours is
getting huge you just devolved back into
Homo erectus Humanity's long extinct
cousin and these changes would have
major consequences on your life another
2 minutes and you'd lose brain capacity
you'd forget how to hunt or Farm
from now on your diet would be limited
you'd eat whatever you could find in the
wild or you could make a trip to the
grocery store while they still exist but
you certainly wouldn't be smart enough
to understand how to pay clothes would
be a thing of the past now you'd be
letting everything hang
free you'd forget everything you
wouldn't know how to bury the dead or
how to create art you'd be naked hungry
kind of dumb and a little uglier the
good news well no one would tell
you after about 4 hours into this
experiment well you'd lose the ability
to talk and as you grunted your way
through life society around you would
start to crumble yeah in the next 2 and
1/2 days cities would become abandoned
ruins of a Time forgotten instead of
living in these buildings you'd prefer
roughing it in Huts now you would
devolve into Homo habilis eating leaves
plants and whatever animal you could
catch with your diminished brain
capacity you wouldn't be able to use
stone tools anymore and a warm fire
would be a rare
luxury after 6 days you'd devolve back
into a chimp you'd be living off The
Spoils of the Jungle eating seeds nuts
and insects over the next couple of
months wild primates would rain on Earth
again okay after 6 months of your
Devolution the lines between species
would blur now you would live among the
monot mammals that lay eggs like the
Platypus yeah you'd be hatched into this
new
world after one year you'd be wallowing
in freshwater habitats with the the
other tetr pods and if that sounds
refreshing well just wait in one more
year you'd live it up as a starfish or a
wormlike creature floating in the ocean
without care the once great species
known as humans would returned to a
single celled bacteria 10 years into
this wild experiment all of human
history your knowledge and experiences
would be gone and you would be reduced
to a tiny Speck
so once you're back in this simple State
could you evolve back into a human again
yeah well probably not we humans evolved
this way thanks to a lot of luck and
specific
circumstances it all depends on the new
conditions on our planet you could
develop blue skin like the navi or even
become
bioluminescent
wow uh maybe you would just be a pile of
slime who
knows listen Devolution is a fun Theory
but it's unlikely to happen like this
the situations that made your ancestors
Branch out from other species don't
exist to make this process happen in
exact reverse order it's not like
pressing
rewind our universe was born bil
millions of years ago and since that
time it's given birth to millions of
galaxies our solar system and who knows
what
else our universe has been evolving for
13.8 billion years but how exactly did
we get here well strap in because today
we're going back in time to explore the
history of the universe in 10
minutes in in the beginning there was
nothing then suddenly the Big Bang
happened and created our
universe yeah okay maybe it's a little
more complicated than that how this
Cosmic event began is largely a mystery
but once it got started it never stopped
within milliseconds particles like
quarks and photons are formed they're
just some of the building blocks that
make up the world you know today a
couple of minutes later more elements
were born protons and neutrons combined
to create elements like helium and dyum
and for the next 400 million years the
universe will continue to rapidly
[Music]
expand after hundreds of millions of
years of chaos and Rapid expansion
things slow down a bit this will begin
the formation of the first structures of
our universe think of these structures
as the ingredients that make up our
Stars galaxies and even planets like
Earth next we see the formation of
primordial gas clouds made up of helium
and hydrogen two of the elements that
were created earlier these gas clouds
have been pulled together over millions
of years through the force of gravity
once they came together over millions of
more years they slowly got denser and
denser
but let's speed this
[Music]
up as our gas clouds are getting closer
and denser they're also getting hotter
once the center of one of these clouds
reaches 10 million de Kelvin it'll
suddenly ignite creating a process known
as nuclear fusion the hydrogen atoms
will combine to form helium releasing an
incredible amount of energy suddenly the
first star in our universe is
born but this isn't the only one Within
These cosmic clouds billions of stars
are now being created and these aren't
just shiny balls of light they're going
to play an integral part in shaping our
universe and not all these stars are
identical as they're born they'll form
into different shapes and sizes some
will be massive blue giants While others
will be smaller red
dwarfs and it's not just their size
that's different stars have different
lifespans too some live for tens of
millions of years While others live for
trillions and as we've been observing
these Stars something fascinating has
been happening these Stars don't like to
chill in Space by themselves they want
to group together and it just so happens
that when these Stars along with other
particles like gas dark dark matter and
dust grouped together due to
gravitational forces they form
galaxies yeah galaxies like the Milky
Way and Andromeda were formed in this
way but that won't be for a couple more
billion
years over hundreds of millions of years
the universe continued to expand more
galaxies formed and they began to evolve
in fascinating ways in a common theme
we've been seeing throughout our travels
the galaxies started to gravitate toward
each other as these galaxies begin to
pull together they create Galaxy
clusters these are the largest
gravitational structures we know of at
this time we're also seeing some of the
stars that formed near the beginning of
the universe starting to die out they're
exploding into
supernovas but don't be sad that they're
dying these supernovas are a necessary
sacrifice to provide the universe with
essential elements that will later
create planets and
life speaking of essential elements I
should also mention Dark
Matter this is a mysterious substance
that doesn't emit or absorb any light
and plays a pivotal role in the tapestry
of the
universe even though we can't see dark
matter we know that it has a strong pole
that has helped shape everything up
until now dark matter is like a hidden
framework that's helped form our galaxy
clusters and other elements of the
[Music]
universe okay now is when things get a
little more familiar after several
smaller galaxies come together the Milky
Way begins to
form our sister Galaxy the androma
Galaxy is also created during this time
and in other similar galaxies so solar
systems are starting to be created
enormous clouds of gas and dust collapse
under their own gravity bonding together
and creating early planets and solar
systems and it only gets more
interesting from
here okay we've been away for a couple
billion years and during that time the
universe has continued to expand more
solar systems and galaxies are formed
and way more stars have been created
well speaking of stars arguably the most
important star in all of space was born
our
son after our sun is born extra gas and
dust surround it over time these
particles Clump together eventually
growing larger and larger this process
is called planetesimals the beginning of
the planets we know today in our solar
system over time these planetesimals
grow larger and larger through countless
collisions and gravitational attractions
one of these protoplanets that's
emerging is Earth its growth is marked
by a pivotal event a Mars sized body
known as Thea crashes into our
planetesimal which creates what we now
call Earth and our moon similar
collisions of celestial bodies create
the other rocky planets we know today
mer Mercury Venus and
Mars over in the cooler regions of space
further away from the Sun gas giants
like Jupiter and Saturn are forming but
checking back in on our rocky planets
they look significantly different than
they do in the present day they're a lot
smoother than I remember well just wait
a couple more million years for what's
known as the late heavy bombardment to
occur this Cosmic event saw massive
asteroids hit these rocky planets it
played a huge role in how they're shaped
today okay after billions and billions
of years we finally start to see life
appear in our
universe but don't get too excited these
are simple single celled organisms known
as
procaryotes they lack many of the
essential features for today but are
still an important part of our Evolution
you currently have trillions of them
living on your body not long after this
oxygen begins to appear on Earth and so
do multicell organisms earth's climate
is beginning to take shape and we see
the introduction of the ozone layer
which protects life from harmful
radiation from
space okay another couple billion years
have passed and a lot has happened
happened the organisms that were
microscopic have evolved to become
creatures with vertebrae this is a
significant Milestone and a precursor to
all other vertebrate life on Earth
including
you and even more change happens during
this time plants are evolving and
continents are
moving this is the age of reptiles and
Pangia but it also had its
shortcomings a mass extinction event
occurs wiping out a vast majority of the
species that have been so patiently
evolving this sets the stage for
dinosaurs and mammals to emerge and as
this era comes to a close Pangia begins
to fragment laying the groundwork for
our modern
continents and now we're here I love you
like la la la la la la la la la la I
love you like la la la la about 50,000
years ago we shared this planet with
different hominids called the
neandertals their species wasn't human
but they weren't far from it either no
longer walking Among Us these early
cousins of humans died out long ago but
not before they had a chance to uh get
intimate with some of our
ancestors if you were to mate with a
neander today what would your children
look
like would your relationship stay
monogamous and how much money would you
spend on a
date this is what if and here's what
would happen if you made it with a
neander with their protruding brows and
large MERS a neander may not be the most
attractive partner available but
considering that 20% of neandertal DNA
is found in humans across the globe they
might have had a little something going
on after all our bodies are entirely
compatible and these primitive features
might trigger something Primal in you
and while you might have a wild night
out would you be able to speak the same
language
let's clear a few important things up
humans did not evolve from neandertals
our species and theirs came from a
common ancestor over a half million
years ago then like two branches on the
same tree we both went our separate ways
neandertals roamed Eurasia while humans
were starting to migrate Out of Africa
but due to inbreeding and smaller
population size size the neander TS
slowly faded out of existence and if
they were still around today our Jean
Pool might look wildly different but
before you start painting the nursery
let's start talking about your
matches again you may not find neander
TS uh conventionally attractive but they
weren't the lumbering oos from our
imaginations our primitive cousins were
adept at hunting and killed large
animals at close range they made many
tools and even created jewelry these
strong and fierce hominids would be able
to protect you bring home dinner and
even make you an anniversary gift but
you'd want to Dy in more often
especially when you consider that
neander TS would eat 700 calories more
than humans per day they might be
primitive but they wouldn't be a cheap
date also considering that neander calls
often ate the contents inside their
prey's stomach their table manners might
be a little bit messy but even then
there might be an attraction you
couldn't deny so what would attract you
to in the
anderol most of our human desires are
ruled by the specific mate recognition
system this means you're attracted to
individuals you feel comfortable with so
anyone who triggers the right anatomical
behav Behavioral or chemical cues in you
could cause an intense attraction but
hey you like whoever you like
unfortunately for you though a
relationship with a neander wouldn't be
exclusive neandertals lived in small
communities and inbreeding was a common
practice so your potential in-laws would
all be fierce competition for your
partner's
affection our skin and hair still
contain genes from neander tall's
surviving
genomes while your children would have a
full head of hair they could suffer from
blood clots and be more at risk for
catching communicable diseases like
covid-19 and depending on your partner
your hybrid Offspring might have trouble
reproducing mating between human females
and male neander tals would be less
likely to produce fertile children
neandertals were known for their broad
noses and protruding brows based on
fossils found from these human
neandertal pairings your kids might not
inherit those features but they could
have massive molers a large bone behind
their ear or frontal face flattening
Flathead syndrome isn't lethal for
infants but it can be costly to correct
involving physical therapy or expensive
corrective helmet
hel humans mating with neander tals
didn't keep their species going but
their legacy lives on in our
DNA wait a minute neanderthals are
extinct before you laugh check yourself
Neanderthal DNA is
99.7% identical to our own and
researchers claim that some humans might
be carrying as much as 2% of the
Neanderthal genome making things even
weirder is that scientists recently
recovered a nearly complete DNA sequence
from a 50,000-year old Neanderthal
skeleton so in theory neanderthals could
make a comeback but how would they adapt
and how long would they
survive this is what if and here's what
would happen if neanderthals hadn't gone
extinct
despite their physical differences like
being shorter and having longer skulls
we might have more in common with
neanderthals than we'd like to admit
first of all their brains were bigger
which doesn't make them smarter than us
but they could communicate with one
another they settled in family
communities and took care of the sick
and the elderly they also crafted
sophisticated tools which would have
been used for anything from hunting to
possibly ship building they even cook
their vegetables and ate them which is
more than you can say so if neanderthals
are simply the beta version of what
humans became could they still live
among us neanderthals in fact did live
among us for about 5,000 years Homo
sapiens and Neanderthals coexisted in
Europe and likely
interbred this would explain why most
eurasians probably have at least 1% of
the Neanderthal DNA in their genome
while anyone of African descent doesn't
have any Neanderthal DNA since their
ancestors didn't migrate through Eurasia
but with the homo sapien population
significantly outnumbering the
Neanderthal population it's likely that
modern humans simply absorbed the
Neanderthal
species another theory is that we outc
competed them for resources during the
last ice age resulting in their
Extinction But whichever theory is right
what if the concluding fact was wrong
what if neanderthals were not
extinct if neanderthals somehow evolved
as a separate but very similar species
to humans how would they fare despite
their communication and craftsmanship
abilities the laws of natural selection
prove that homo sapiens are superior
which means the survival options for
neanderthals wouldn't be that great
barring the likelihood of early modern
humans breeding them out of existence
neanderthals probably would have become
something like second class citizens
would we enslave them keep them in zoos
or force them to fight it's hard to say
with the limits of their intelligence
prevent them from fully integrating into
modern society or would they learn and
evolve just like Homo
sapiens maybe they'd want nothing to do
with us realizing how our differences
outweigh our similarities could we
expect neanderthals to establish their
own communities and continue to exist
independently of the developing world
it's hard to predict exactly how a
species that went extinct about 40,000
years ago would behave today but then
again maybe we just have to look around
us neanderthals may be extinct but we
did evolve alongside them and some of us
inherited more than others so think
twice before you call someone a
neanderthal it can be quite
offensive 1,000 years into the future
humans might look like
this this is Mindy a model that shows
what we humans might look like in the
year
3000 equipped with a hunched over back
Claws and a smaller brain Mindy has
adapted this way primarily due to
technology and cell phones but this is
just a start of a potential evolutionary
journey of the human
body Let's Travel 1 million years into
the future to see the even crazier ways
our bodies will
evolve super strength giant eyes and
edited jeans are all things you might
see later in this
episode but why are we getting all these
traits anyway well more on that in a
second but for now let's check in and
see what the next phase of evolution is
for
humans 5,000 years into the
future okay we're now several thousand
years into the the future and in many
ways humans would look relatively
similar to how we do now yeah if we look
5,000 years into the past from where we
are today well humans look basically the
same the main differences are that well
we're now healthier taller and stronger
this is primarily due to how our diet
health care and lifestyle have changed
throughout the
centuries this is speculation but you
can assume that a lot will have happened
5,000 years into the future changes that
include space travel and massive
advancements in technology and
Ai and how we look all depends on where
humans decide to live in the
future if Humanity becomes an
Interstellar civilization well we might
look like
this and if we stay on Earth and go all
in on AI well humans might look more
like this
so we'll explore a couple of options as
we move through the years the
generations of humans who decide to go
to Mars will notice the most significant
changes Mars's lower gravity would lead
to less bone density and muscle mass but
the change in gravity might also lead to
increased height and longer Limbs and
there'll be a lot more changes coming up
but for now let's take another jump into
the future and check on some other
options for human evolution 25,000 years
into the
future it's safe to say that technology
will play a heavy role in how humans
evolve traveling 25,000 years into the
future well you might decide to have a
designer baby instead of creating life
naturally and leaving so many things to
chance you would select various traits
for who you want your baby to be you
could choose physical characteristics of
like hair and eye color and much more
essential features like the ability to
avoid certain diseases and
allergies in a way this is already
happening today but in the future it'll
be more advanced and accessible it's
also likely that humans will begin to
fuse with technology becoming cyborg
like
beings think neural links robot Limbs
and sensory
enhancements imagine having a chip in
your brain that's equipped with an AI
that provides you with any answer you
need humans will have all these
cybernetic enhancements that will make
them smarter stronger and able to live
longer 100,000 years into the
future one of the ways which we can see
how much humans have evolved is by
looking at our faces and heads as you
see here in 100,000 years our eyes and
heads will be significantly larger this
will will be due to multiple reasons one
of them being that we'll be living in
different environments like space our
larger eyes will allow us to see better
in low light environments it'll also
help protect our eyes from the cosmic
rays found in space on Mars along with
bones becoming less dense and limbs
continuing to get longer residents there
will need to develop some new survival
traits to last this long as Humanity has
developed on Mars over the Generations
well they've been experiencing tons of
radiation in their environment that's
thanks to the lack of an atmosphere on
the red planet over time humanity there
has slowly adapted to this new way of
life but the radiation levels are so
harsh that they likely haven't adapted
enough to live
comfortably one of the problems with
evolution is that it's incredibly slow
seeing significant change in our bodies
can take millions of years so to fix
that we'll need to make some changes
ourselves you'll see what I mean as we
continue on to our 1 million year
mark
250,000 years into the
future yeah Humanity was tired of
waiting and waiting for changes in
evolution to happen so they've decided
to do it themselves we've been altering
our bodies with technology for hundreds
of thousands of years at this point but
now we're going to take it to another
level yeah instead of adding some sort
of enhancement to our bodies well we'll
now alter our DNA with Advanced genetic
manipulation scientists are already
experimenting with this technology but
250,000 years from now well you can bet
the science will be Advanced beyond
belief scientists will be able to alter
edit and even add different genetic
mutations both before people are born
and
after in the case of our Colony on Mars
well people on that planet could alter
their genes so that the radiation isn't
as harmful to their bodies and that's
just the start eventually we'll alter
our genes to produce all sorts of insane
attributes you could be brilliant have
super strength or be immune to every
disease as Humanity unlocks this new era
of human evolution things are about to
get even better
by the way are you wondering where we've
been getting all these crazy video ideas
lately well they come from our patreon
we've got an exclusive Discord where
members get front-of-the-line access to
talk about the what if ideas they want
made sign up and maybe we'll create your
next
idea 500,000 years into the
future okay it's been another 250,000
years Humanity has been playing around
with this Gene editing thing and it's
gotten pretty ridiculous scientists have
managed to combine parts of lizard dna
with our human DNA this has allowed us
to regrow our Limbs and grow new organs
if we need them also along with the help
of technology and Gene editing humans
are more intelligent than ever we can
now naturally have any appearance we
want
this might sound kind of scary but Gene
editing like this will likely be
essential for us to survive in new
environments like space and our evolving
Earth 1 million years into the
future so remember the humans back on
Earth the ones who were adding tons of
cybernetic enhancements to their bodies
yeah they've continued to do that along
with tons of Gene editing and the people
in space have been doing the same thing
but as we've been progressing through
these 1 million years well the
environments on Earth and Mars have been
very different and because of these
different environments the humans living
on these planets would have different
needs and desires for the types of
bodies they
want remember evolution is all about
lifestyle and environment that's why
Mindy at the start looked the way she
did it's possible that the humans living
on these two planets would be so
different that they'd essentially be two
completely separate species sort of like
50,000 years ago when there were humans
on Earth at the same time as
neandertals but regardless of how
they're different it's likely that both
types of future humans will be the most
advanced species ever seen we'll live
longer maybe forever be smarter than
ever and be ready to to take on whatever
challenges the future
holds all good things must come to an
end sadly Homo sapiens time on Earth is
no exception and someone would surely
take our place as the dominant species
but who or rather
what how could genetic engineering spell
out the end for our
species what would distinguish the next
homo species from
us and could the world's next dominant
species not be human at
all this is what if and here's what
would happen if Homo sapiens went
extinct some of the earliest species of
humans date back at least 7 million
years
back then different humanoid species
belonging to the huminity family walked
amongst each other they evolved
interbred and way more often than not
died out our species Homo sapiens
arrived on the scene about 6 million
years ago but it wasn't until some point
in the last 15,000 to 40,000 years that
we emerged as the only living species of
humans and not long after that we had
settled on every continent except for
Antarctica our social Innovation and
Tool creation are some of the factors
you could thank for this these skills
allowed us to out compete other species
like
neandertals and this Innovative nature
could be what leads to our very own
demise when we create a new superhuman
species that could outlive us all
according to the author Don simborg our
successors or homo Nuvo would look more
or less just like you the big difference
these humanoids would be more like a
highly engineered version homon nuuvo
would be created through the selective
editing of our genes their genes could
be manipulated so that they grow taller
age slower or no longer contract certain
diseases
and should these new humans not
interbreed with us they could be on
their own distinct evolutionary path
thanks to Natural Selection they could
start looking and acting differently
from us Homo
sapiens now while this could sound like
something out of a sci-fi film it could
be closer than you think it took modern
humans about 200,000 years to evolve
from our morar aric predecessors but
homo Nuvo could come into existence in a
matter of
decades this could be largely thanks to
crisper and no that's not the hottest
new kitchen appliance it's an acronym
for clustered regularly interspaced
short palindromic
repeats in other words genetic editing
using this method you could add remove
or alter particular locations in an
organism's DNA you could use it to
prevent and treat diseases by making
edits to somatic cells in your body
these changes you make to your own
genome couldn't be passed on to your
children but should you start tinkering
with the genetic sequences of your eggs
or sperm cells you could be laying out
the red carpet for our successor
species next gen crisper created humans
could have genetically modified Heights
and muscle masses to go along with their
customized skin hair and eye colors and
over time there could be an intersection
of both natural and unnatural selection
desirable traits could emerge as
dominant ones these new humans could
digest food differently be less prone to
disease and be better adapted to the
effects of climate change they could
withstand more extreme temperatures be
less reliant on nutrients and water or
be more resilient to
radiation this would be a particularly
huge Advantage should interplanetary
space travel be common in the
future but things wouldn't necessarily
be all peaches and sunshine for this
future species dangers and unexpected
challenges could present themselves when
we play such a Godlike role in our own
evolutionary path editing just one gene
in a single individual with the hope of
achieving a specific result could have
far-reaching unintended consequences and
these consequences could then be
inherited by this person's children and
their children's
children now while it may sound fun to
manipulate our physiological
characteristics it wouldn't be so simple
to engineer humans to be more
intelligent there are thousands of genes
linked to your IQ and they rely on many
complex interactions messing around with
these genes could have disastrous
outcomes imagine more and more humans
suffering from behavioral conditions
like Tourette Syndrome or attention
deficit disorder whether on purpose or
accidental these could be encoded by
only a few genes and since these are
hereditary they could be passed on but
then again as Gene editing advances you
could also see these disorders
eliminated
entirely these homon nuuvo could also
combine their genetically modified
traits with cyborg Technologies they
could retrieve information at lightning
speed enhance their Vision with infrared
to see at night or become super soldiers
by hooking themselves up directly to
machines like fighter jets competing
with homon Nuvo for survival would be an
increasingly difficult situation for us
mere humans and eventually it could be
the end of us of course there's always
the chance that a nonhuman entity could
surpass us before they do like
artificial super
intelligence but that's a story for
another what
if
in the past few billion years Earth has
been pummeled by asteroids crashed into
other planets and frozen over several
times not to mention being ruled by